hey how's your meeting
good i'll fill you in later you ready
for your speech
uh yeah yeah thank you julie
it is so inspiring to hear stories of
powerful women
who are held in high esteem by their
hometowns now
from the hometown of pawnee indiana in
the united states
leslie knope
uh first let me say it is a true honor
to be here among these amazing women
you all inspire me with your
accomplishments and the things you have
done for your hometowns
and the things your hometowns have done
for you i mean they're just truly
you know i've been a public servant for
a long time and you know how i spend my
days
cleaning slime out of rivers and
removing slugs from people's front yards
and i love my town but you know how they
repay me by hating me
they hate me they want to recall me i
wish i could
uh move to silkeborg and dance with a
reindeer you're always welcome in
silicon borg
olga let's start a statue of leslie see
they like me in silkenborg more than my
own hometown and i've never even been
there
i love pawnee but sometimes it sucks
the people can be very mean and
ungrateful and they cling to their fried
dough
and they're big sodas and then they get
mad at me when their pants don't fit
you know i'm sick of it pawnee is filled
with a bunch of pee-pee heads
thank you very much for this amazing
award i'm sorry i said pee-pee heads
that's my boss
okay let's fake this candle okay tracy
they are ready for your acceptance
speech in
three two one
oh people at pacific rim how you feel
all right i'd like to thank my wife
my two sons tracy junior and george
foreman this josh dude
liz lemon uh ball-headed people setting
up the satellite
and of course a very special blonde lady
shelley long you're truly an inspiration
to me i know that
and finally i'd like to thank you
pacific rimmers for all that you've
given us
a karaoke karate and most of
all
shark attack and
this next award is going out to our own
little pam beasley i think we all know
what award pam is going to be getting
this year
it is the whitest sneakers award
because she always has the whitest
tennis shoes on down oh here we
[Applause]
many people to go for this award
okay first off my kids because i
couldn't have done it without them
thank you let's give michael a round of
applause for emceeing tonight because
this is a lot harder than it looks and
also
because of dwight too um
so finally i want to thank god
because god gave me this dundee
and i feel god in this chili's tonight
every award from the smallest trophy
to the nobel prize is nothing more than
is nothing more than a great way to
honor someone
so i would like to present this year's
dottie english
whatever award to the person who
actually deserves it
leslie knope come on up here leslie
thank you i don't know what to say um
honestly i'm just very honored to work
for someone as insightful and kind
as my boss so i would like to present
this year's dorothy everton smythe award
to ron swanson
i don't want it just take it down you
deserve it no no really
no ron you deserve it really but i don't
want it but you want it and you should
win it
after that whole conversation i'm being
ridiculous just could someone please
just take it
okay i'll take it who do i speak to
about getting this changed get off the
stage
yeah i still think awards are stupid
but they'd be less stupid if they went
to the right people
you